We conclude Virgil's the iniad today.
And as we've discussed, Virgil is very
much the anti-homer.
Okay.
And so what
the INIAD
is is really a response to the Iliad and
the Odyssey. Remember Homer believes
that love is the unifying force of the
universe. It is a center is what gives
you life. It g it's what gives you
purpose and hope. For Virgil, what
matters is the idea of piety
or obedience
to
the gods
and to your father.
And um as we discussed, Virgil sets up a
very stark contrast between love and
piety where they are competing forces.
You cannot love and be pious at the same
time. And piety is ultimately the man
the main centralizing force of the
universe. If you are pious, if you obey
the gods, then the world will be right
because the gods have a divine
plan for the world. And in the case of
the Iniad, it is the founding of the
empire of Rome, which is Inias's
um mission and purpose.
And so our role, our responsibility, our
duty in life is just to follow this path
of the gods and then the world will be
perfect. Okay. Um
this will the the INIAD will create the
Roman Empire
which will then become the Catholic
Church
and the Catholic Church will rule for
over a thousand years. Okay, the
millennium.
And during this thousand years, it is a
time of
uh conformity of stagnation. And it is
because in this time
what is often referred to as the dark
ages, Virgil becomes the god of the
Catholic Church, the central organizing
force. Why? Because every children,
sorry, every child of the elite
memorizes the Iniad.
And so every child perceives the world
through the lens of the Iniad. And um so
what will happen is to destroy this
empire a man will emerge to liberate the
human imagination and his name of course
is Dante. Okay. And Dante will destroy
the Roman Empire and the Catholic Church
with his masterpiece divine comedy. We
will spend the rest of the semester
reading the Divine Comedy. It's not
something you can read by yourself.
There's absolutely no point. You know,
if I just give it to you and it's like
go read it, it will make no sense to
you. We have to go through line by line,
word by word for you to understand the
divine comedy. Because not only is it
poetry, but it's philosophy.
And what poets will tell you is that a
poem is just truth told with as few
beautiful words as possible. So it could
just be a few lines but it could take
you a lifetime to fully understand the
true meaning of these lines. And that is
what the divine comedy is. It's a very
um it's an epic poem but each paragraph
each sent uh each um each line is a
truth an eternal truth onto itself.
Okay. So we'll read divine comedy line
by line
um and we'll try to really understand
it. But again, the point of this class
is not to tell you what the book great
books are. The the entire point of the
class is to get you excited about
entering a journey that is great books
that that will take you entire lifetime.
Okay? It will take you entire lifetime
to appreciate the the genius of these
great books. And uh this class is is
meant to be a starting point. Okay. So
do not think at the end of of this
class, oh I've read Homer, I've read
Virgil, I've read Dante, so I know the
great books. No. Okay. This is just the
beginning. All right. So where we are in
the story of the Iniad is
that Inias gets gets shipwrecked.
Um, and he becomes a a guest of Ditto,
the queen of Carthage.
And the two fall in love. Ditto falls in
love with the fact that Inias is not
just a great warrior and very handsome,
but also be because he's a great
storyteller. He tells her the story of
the fall of uh, Troy. And the two fall
in love. And Ditto has this burning
passion for Inas. and the gods of and
the gods uh um basically Juno wants to
thwart the possibility of the rise of
the Roman Empire. And so uh she
conspires to have Ditto and and Inas
consummate their passion for each other
and then they get married. But then uh
Jo the king of the gods finds about this
and says no no no this is not part of
the plan. Inis is not supposed to fall
in love with Ditto, stay in Carthage,
and build the Carthaginian Empire. He's
supposed to go to Rome. So, he sends
Mercury, the messenger of the gods, down
to
um Inas and tells him, "Hey man, what
are you doing? This is not your duty. Do
your duty." Okay, so um this is where we
are.
in the story. Okay. So, let us um read.
Okay. Uh I read you read, please.
>> Mercury. Mercury lashes out at once. You
So now you lay foundation stones for the
soaring walls of Carthage, building her
gorgeous city, doing on your wife, blind
to your own realm, oblivious to your
fate. The king of the gods, whose power
sways earth and sky. He is the one who
sends me down from brilliant Olympus,
bearing commands for you through the
racing winds. What are you plotting now?
Wasting time in Libya. What hope
misleads you so? If such a glorious
destiny cannot fire your spirit, if you
will not shoulder the task for your own
fame, at least remember Eskeinius rising
into his prime, the hopes you lodge
Anelas, your only heir.
>> Okay. All right. So Eskinius of course
is Inas's father and Ilas is the son.
Okay. Who will inherit the um legacy
going? You owe him Italy's realm, the
land of Rome. This order still on his
lips. The god vanished from sight into
empty air. Then Anias was truly
overwhelmed by division. Stunned. His
hackles bristle with fear. His voice
chokes in his throat. He yearns to be
gone, to desert this land he loves,
thunder struck by the warnings Jupiter's
command. But what can he do? What can he
dare say now to the queen in all her
fury and win her over? Where to where to
begin? What opening? Thoughts racing
here, there, probing his options,
turning to this plan, that plan, torn in
two, until at his wit's end, this answer
seems the best. Okay. So again, Virgil
is the uh anti-H Homer. And what I mean
by that is that if Homer were writing
this, then what Homer would emphasize is
how emotional emotionally conflicted
Inas is because he loves Ditto. He does
not want to go. For Homer, love is above
the gods.
And what a human is is someone who
aspires to love. And when we read divine
comedy, what we will discover is this.
The reason why is because
God is love. Okay?
And there's an aspect of God in us, a
candle that strives to return to the
light. And so we seek love. And so for
Homer doing a choice between going to
Rome and finding a great empire or
staying in Carthage and being with
Ditto, obviously you choose Ditto
because that is the path to God, right?
And that's what happened in the Odyssey
where Odysius had an opportunity to stay
with Calypso and have uh and live
forever. Uh but he chooses to return to
Penelp. And when he returns to Penelope,
Penelope asked him, "Will you ever leave
me again?" And she and he says, "Never
again will I leave you because this is
my home. Love is where my heart is."
Okay, so this is the um so but what the
conflict is in Inas is okay, I will get
the hell out of here. I've risen with
fear because what I fear most is the
anger of the gods. What I must do is be
loyal to the gods and heed their
command. So screw love. I don't need
this. But there's a problem which is how
do I actually
tell Ditto? All right, that's a
conflict. Not should I leave Ditto, but
like how do I get out of here without
her bitching at me? All right.
And so what does he decide to do? He
decides I won't tell her. Yeah, that's
it. I'll pretend this didn't happen and
then at night I will just sneak away and
then well who cares what happens
afterwards. All right. So this is so the
thing to notice is this is not human.
Okay. There's nothing human about Inas.
What he is is he's a he's like a walking
fallus almost.
He's like James Bond man, you know?
He goes around, does his mission, sleeps
with w with a lot of girls and then runs
off. All right.
So, uh let us continue. Um
uh I he summons Netheus sir Gestus stus
gives m orars fit out the fleet but not
a word. Mustard cruise on shore. All
tackle set to sail. But the cause for
our new course, you keep it secret. Yet
he himself, since the who means the
world to him, knows nothing. Never
dreaming such a powerful love could be
uprooted. He will try to approach her,
find a moment to break the news gently,
a way to soften the blow that he must
leave. All ship may snap to command,
glad to do his orders. True, but queen,
who can delude a lover? soon caught wind
of a plot of foot. The first to sense
the Trojans are on the move. She fears
everything now, even with all secure.
Rumor, vicious as ever, brings her word,
already distraught, that Trojans.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Um, you know what? Uh,
sorry.
Who are you?
>> are rigging out their galleys, gearing
to set sail. She rages in. She rages in
helpless frenzy, blazing through the
entire city, raving like some main main
driven wild when the women shake the
sacred emblems. When the cyclic orgy
shouts of bakus fire her on and
>> cithan
>> ciththeron echoes round with madden
midnight cries.
>> Okay. All right. So certain things to
notice. Okay. Um Bakus is the god of
creativity
of um god of creativity for the Greeks.
So there actually two gods of creativity
in the Greek world. There's Apollo and
there's Dianis Bakis. Okay, Apollo is
the god of logical creativity where you
sit down calmly and then you write down
your thoughts. Okay, that's a polo. Then
you have Bakis who's the god of
emotional rapturous creativity where you
get drunk, you have a lot of sex and
then you express yourself. Okay. And for
the Greeks, these are two aspects of
creativity that you both need in order
to fully achieve your human potential.
Yes, uh you need to be engaged in
meditation, in rational analysis, but
you also need to fully explore the
possibilities of your emotions to just
let go, to be crazy, to be frenzy. Okay?
And what Virgil is saying is that we
must the backest aspect is actually the
worst type of emotion because it leads
you into madness. Okay. All right.
So um
can reading uh Ivory
>> at last she asses an before he said a
word. So you traitor, you really
believed you'd keep this a secret, this
great outrage. Seal away in silence from
my shores. Can nothing hold you back?
Not our love. Not the pledge when sealed
with our right hands. Not even the
thought of ditto doomed to a cruel
death.
>> Okay. Stop. Okay. All right. So this
line, not the pledge once sealed with
our right hands. This is an illusion of
course to
um
right here. Okay. This is illusion of
course to the Odyssey where
Odysius and Penelpi meet again for the
first time in 20 years and Penelope
basically says to Odysius
convince me that you actually know my
husband. And Odysius says, "Well,
because of this uh ornament that Penelpi
gave to Odysius, right?" And that
ornament of course is the pledge
sealed with their love for each other.
And this pledge, this memory, this bond
is what carries them for eternity. So
that even though they are a great
distance from each other, their hearts
are still conjoined together.
And so what D says is does this pledge
mean nothing to you Inas and Inas of
course is like it it's a word it's
nothing
all right what matters is your oath to
the gods what matters is your loyalty to
the gods
I keep reading
>> why labor to rig your fleet when the
winter's raw to risk the deep wind the
north winds closing in you cruel
heartless
Even if you were not pursuing alien
fields and unknown homes, even if
ancient Troy were still standing, still
who sail for Troy across such heaving
seas, you're running away from me. Oh, I
pray you by these tears, by the faith in
your right hand. What else have I left
myself in all my pain? by our wedding
vows, the marriage we began. If I
deserve some decency from you now, if
anything mine has ever won your heart,
pity a great house about to fall. I pray
you if prayers have any place, reject
this scheme of yours. Thanks to you, the
African tribes, nubian warlords hate me.
Even my own tyrants rise against me.
Thanks to you, my sense of honor is
gone. My one and only pathway to the
stars, the renown I once held dear. In
whose hands my guest do you leave me
here to meet my death?
>> All right. Okay. So two things to to
remember. Okay. The first thing is that
in the Odyssey
the journey where it ends the
destination is towards home to be with
Penelope again to be a family again.
Okay. And that is the end of this epic
journey. But in the indiad, it's the
reverse where you start off with a
relationship with love and then you have
to abandon love in order to go on this
epic journey to to found the empire of
Rome. Okay? So you see how it's it's
inverse. Now in the Odyssey, the entire
purpose of your life is to return home
and to be in love, to fall in love.
Okay? But in the IMIAD,
love is what you have to abandon in
order to fully fulfill your destiny.
Okay, that's number one. Number two is
this. What um
um D is saying is thanks to you, I've
lost everything. Okay. So love, my love
for you means I have to abandon my
pride, my reputation, my own people.
Without love,
sorry because my love for you, I become
nothing. Okay. And this inverses
inversion of what happened in the
Odyssey where
because Odysius sought glory and fame in
war, he became traumatized with PTSD.
He saw the horrors of war where innocent
people, innocent uh families were
destroyed
because of of war and that traumatized
him. And what allowed him to resurrect
himself, what allowed him to escape his
trauma and rebuild his sense of identity
is going home and finding love again.
And this love is able to resurrect his
worldview and give him the courage and
the power to fight on. Okay. So this is
the opposite message of the um Odyssey.
Okay. All right. Let's let's so now
Okay. So, uh, Ditto is saying to Inas,
"You're abandoned me. You tricked me. I
fell in love with you and now you're
abandoning me." And this is,
um, an in response. And, and the human
thing to do would be to show pity,
right? And say to Ditto, Ditto, I'm
really sorry for what happened, but
let's go together. Or maybe, Ditto, I'll
come back for you. Okay.
Instead, he says the worst thing
possible. All right. C can you read it?
>> Guest. That's all that remains of
husband now. But why do I linger on
until my brother Pegalian batters down
my walls or Arabus drags me off his
slave? If only you'd left a baby in my
arms, our child before you deserted me.
some little aneas playing about our
halls whose features at least would
bring you back to me in spite of all I
would not feel so totally devastated, so
destroyed.
The queen stopped, but he warned by
Jupiter now his gaze held steady fought
to master the torment in his heart. At
last he ventured
>> torment in his heart is not sadness but
anger. Okay, come on going.
>> At last he ventured a few words. I You
could have done me so many kindnesses
and you could count them all. I shall
never deny what you deserve, my queen.
Never regret my memories of ditto. Not
while I can recall myself and draw the
breath of life.
>> Hey, one more.
>> I'll state my case in a few words. I
never dreamed I'd keep my flight a
secret. Don't imagine that. Nor did I
once extend a bridegroom's torch or
enter into a marriage pact with you.
Okay. So what he's saying is I we didn't
we did not have a marriage path. Okay.
We're not married. This is not true.
They contemplate the relationship and
everyone witness it. So they are
married. But he's saying we're not
really married. Keep on going.
>> If the face had let me free to live my
life, to arrange my own affairs of my
own free will. Troy is the city first of
all that I'd safeguard. Troy and all
that's left of my people whom I cherish.
The Grand Palace of Prime would stand
once more. With my own hands, I would
fortify a second Troy to house my
Trojans in defeat. But not but not now.
Grian Apollo's oracle says that I must
seize on Italy's noble land. His Lysian
lots say Italy. There lies my love,
there lies my homeland. Now, if you, a
Phoenician, fix your eyes on Carthage, a
Libyan stronghold, tell me, why do you
grudge the Trojans their new homes on
Italian soil? What is the crime if we
seek faroff kingdoms, too?
>> All right. So, what he's saying is this,
Ditto.
Um, if it were up to me,
I wouldn't say we I would say with you
either. Okay. If it were up to me, I
would be back in Troy dying. and
fighting and dying for what I truly
love, which is a city of Troy. Now that
I've lost Troy, I must build an empire.
You have your own empire, Carthage. Why
stop me from building my own empire in
Italy? Okay. So, what matters is not
love. What matters is power.
That's why we live. That's why we exist.
To seek more power.
Love gets in the way and therefore love
must be discarded. You ditto. I do love
you but you're in my way. Therefore get
out of my way.
Right.
All right. So now Ditto is distraught.
She fell in love with Inas and broke her
uh vow to her former husband Sikius. And
now she knows her people um don't
respect her anymore. And she knows that
the neighboring warlords have contempt
for her and they might even attack her
because previously she rebuffed their
advances. So they feel insulted. Um but
at the same time she's still desperately
in love with Inas and she knows he can't
he can't she cannot stop him from
leaving for Italy. And so she decides
eventually that her only solution is
suicide.
But she has um a sister Anna who will
keep watch over her. Okay. So she
develops a very elaborate ploy to kill
herself. All right. Can you read Irene?
>> And now what shall I do? Make a mockery
of myself. Go back to my old suitors.
Tempt them to try again. Beg the
Numidians. Gravel. Plead for a husband.
Though time and again I score into what
they're like. Would then trail the
Trojan ships bend to the Trojans's every
last demand. So pleased are they with
all the help the relief I lend them
once. In memory of my service past
stands firm in grateful minds. And even
if I were willing, would the Trojans
allow me to bore their proud ships? A
woman they hate. Poor lostful. Can't you
sense it? grasp it yet the treachery of
Lamemedin's breed.
What now? Do I take flight alone,
consorting with crews of Trojan horse or
horsemen in their triumph? Or follow
them out with all my troops of tyrants
throwing the decks? Yes, hard as it was
to uproot them once from Ty. How can I
force them back to sea once more?
Command them to spread their sails to
the winds?
No. No. Die. You deserve it. End your
pain with the sword. You, my sister, you
were the first, won over by my tears, to
pile these sorrows on my shoulders, mad
as I was, to throw me into my enemy's
arms. If only I'd been free to live my
life untested in marriage, free of guilt
as some wild beast untouched by pains
like these. I broke the faith. I soar to
the ashes of Sakius.
>> Wait, so again, the idea here is
for Homer, love is what gives you
strength. Love love is what allows you
to resurrect yourself. Okay? So the
metaphor is love is the the bowl of
Odysius, right? Where
this bowl, but this has not touched for
20 years, but the moment he touches it,
it gives him renewed strength and he's
able to um assemble it very quickly and
then shoot the target. Okay, that's the
power of love. But here in the INIAC,
love is complete opposite where by
falling in love, you disintegrate as a
person. So when we first meet Ditto,
she's a proud queen. And now she is a
complete mess. She is emotionally
falling apart. She's being driven into
madness. She's like, should I go and beg
the Trojans to let me on the ship and be
a slave girl? Okay. So, it is the
complete fall of a queen. Okay. From a
queen to essentially to a slave girl.
She's seriously considering being a
slave girl if it just means being near
Inas.
And ultimately, she decides no, my only
option is to uh die. Okay.
All right.
So she is contemplating killing herself
and the gods know this. And so what they
do is they tell Inas in a dream, "Get
out of here because we we don't want you
seeing Ditto kill herself." Okay. Can
you read?
>> Such terrible grief kept breaking from
her heart as Inia slept in peace on his
ship's high stern.
>> Okay. So Ina slept in peace, meaning he
doesn't care. Do you understand? He was
never in love with her. She was just a
play thing. Keep on going.
>> Bent on departing now. All tackle set to
sail. And now in his dreams, it came
again. The god, his phantom, the same
features shining clear like Mercury head
to foot, the voice, the glow, the golden
hair, the bloom of youth on his limbs.
And his voice rang out with warnings
once again. Son of the goddess, how can
you sleep so soundly in such a crisis?
Can't you see the dangers closing around
you now? Madman, can't you hear the west
wind ruffling to speed you on? That
woman plot spawns her plots, mulling
over some desperate outrage in her
heart, lashing her surging range. She's
bent on death. Why not flee headlong?
Flee headlong while you can. You'll soon
see the waves, a chaos of ships, lethal
torches flaring, the whole coast ablaze.
If now a new dawn breaks and finds you
still mingering on these shores, up with
you now, enough delay. Woman's a thing
that's always changing, shifting like
the wind. With that, he vanished into
the black knight.
>> All right, so Inias is running away.
Okay. and Ditto has resolved to kill
herself. And this is her speech
um right before she kills herself. Okay,
can you read after me?
You son whose fires scan all works of
the earth. And you Juno, the witness,
midwife to my agonies. He greeted by
nightly shrieks at city crossroads. And
you you avenging furies and gods of
dying ditto. Hear me. Turn your power my
way. attend my sorrows. I deserve your
mercy. Hear my prayers. If that curse of
the earth much reach his haven, labor on
to landfall. If Joe's in the faith's
command and the boundary stone is fixed,
still let him be plagued in war by a
nation proud in arms, torn from his
borders, wrenched from Ilas's embrace.
Let him gravel for help and watch his
people die a shameful death. And then
once he has bowed down to an unjust
peace, may he never enjoy his realm and
the light he yearns for. Never let him
die before his day unburied on some
desolate beach.
That is my prayer, my final cry. I pour
it out with my own lifeblood. And you,
my tyrants, hairy with hatred, all his
line, his race to come. Make that
offering to my ashes, send it down
below. No love between our peoples ever.
No packs of peace. Come rising up from
my bones. You avengers still unknown to
stalk those Trojan settlers. Hunt with
fire and iron. Now or in time to come.
Whenever the power is yours. Shore clash
with shore. Sea against sea and sword
sword against sword. This is my curse.
War between all our peoples, all their
children. Endless war. Okay.
>> Endless war. Okay. All right. So the
iniad is first and foremost political
propaganda.
All right. And so
um
Rome's epic war is with Carthage. Rome
and Carthage fought for about 100 years
for control of the Mediterranean.
Ultimately Rome will triumph over
Carthage and they will destroy Carthage
as a civilization. They will burn
Carthage down.
And today we have no memory of Carthage.
Being so complete was the destruction.
And
um
Virgil is trying to explain to us why
this had to happen. And it had to happen
because Ditto put a curse
on Rome and forced her people to go to
war with Rome. So it's not that Rome was
vicious and savage in destroying
Carthage. It was like the Carthaginians
had a curse. They had a mission to
avenge Ditto. Okay. So, let me explain
to you how this propaganda works in
Carthage uh understanding of Ditto.
She's the founder. She's the queen of
Carthage. What happened was that you
know she her husband was killed in
Phoenicia. So, she and some refugees
sought refuge in Northern Africa. So
they found the city of Carthage and they
worked really hard to build the city and
she was very attractive. So she um won
the attention of some local warlords and
they demanded her hand in marriage and
her response was to kill herself
and by killing herself that her
sacrifice emboldened her people to build
a great city but also um it won the
respect of the local warlords as well.
And from then on everyone understood the
contents as a free and proud people who
would rather die for the liberty than
than become a slave. Okay. So that's the
contentian understanding of Ditto. Here
in the Iniad it is almost the reverse
where Ditto uh Ditto's love for Inas
becomes a poison. It poisons her soul
and it leads her to poison her people as
well. And rather than give them freedom,
she enslaves them into a mission to
avenge her. Okay? So it's basically
inversion. Right? So that's what the
Indian is doing. This inverting Homer,
but it's also inverting history to serve
the political purposes of Rome. Right?
All right. So we come to the ending of
the um uh Iniad. So with the with the
story of Ditto, what what Ver what
Virgil is doing is inverting the story
of the Odyssey. Now we come to the
ending of the Iliad. And here Virgil is
going to invert the story of the Iliad.
Okay, remember recall what happened in
the Iliad where Achilles tricks Petroas
into sacrificing himself and this allows
Achilles an excuse to enter the
battlefield against Hector. He kills
Hector and he believes that this is the
height the apex of his glory but instead
it causes him in to fall into a deep
depression and it's really prying
willingness to forgive him because of
his love for Hector that frees Achilles
from his guilt and the two Achilles and
Pry cry together and they become friends
because of this. Okay. So, the Iliad is
fundamentally a story of the curse of
power, the evil of power and the ability
of love to both redeem and to save.
What Virgil is going to do is take the
story of the Iliac and invert it. Okay.
So it so it ends actually with um with
an analogy to the battle between
Achilles and Hector. Okay. So in the
Iliad is between Achilles
and Hector. But here it's going to be
between Inas
and Turnis. Okay. So what happened is
that Inias lands in Italy and the Latin
tribes see Inas as his great hero and
the king there Latinist marries
his daughter to um Inias but the wife
for whatever reason like the woman in
the in the u in the all all the villains
okay the the wife the queen has already
promised her daughter to Chis who is
another warlord. And so this starts off
a war between the Trojans and Churnis.
Okay. And ultimately this leads to a
final conflict, a great battle between
Inas and Churnis. Okay. So th this is
the very ending
of the Inia. Okay. Okay. Can can you
read um Ivory? As he hangs back, the
fatal spear of Eno streaks on, spotting
a lucky opening he had flung from a
distance. All his might in Maine. Rocks
heaved up by a catapult pounding city
ramparts never stormed so loudly. Never
such a shadowing bolt of thunder
crashing forth. Like a black whirlwind
churning on that spear flies on with its
weight of iron death to pierce
of the round shield with it. Seven plies
and right at the thick of turn's thigh
it whizzes through. It strikes home and
the blow drops gray turness and the blow
drops gray turnest down to the ground
batter down on his bent knees. The
reptilians spring up with a groan and
the hillsides round grow back grown back
and the tall groves far and wide resound
with the long drawn moan turn his lord
his eyes and reached with his light with
his with his right hand and begged a
suppliant I deserve it all no mercy
please turn his pleaded seize your
moment now or if some care for a
parent's grief can touch you still I
pray you you had such a father in old
antresses pi donis in his old age and
send me back to my own people. Or if you
would prefer, send them my dead body
stripped of life. Here, the victor and
vanquished, I stretch my hands to you,
so the men in Latium have seen me in
defeat. Levvenia is your bride. Go no
further down the road of hatred.
>> Okay. All right. All right. Okay. So
again, this is a rewriting of a battle
between Hector and Achilles. But in this
battle, it is Hector who wins and
Achilles is basically begging for mercy.
And what's really interesting is that to
beg for mercy, uh, Churnis basically
uses the words of Pry from the Iliad,
right? Remember what Prime says to
Achilles is, I've kissed your hand. Have
mercy for me. Look at my face. Remember
of your father, Achilles. Remember your
father, Pelus. Okay. same exact words,
right?
Care for parents grieve. Okay.
And I stretch my hands to you, right?
So, so, so basically Virg is
plagiarizing Homer, but he's
plagiarizing a way as to invert and
subvert Homer. Okay. So,
at at this point, um, Inias is drawn to
pity, right? because his great enemy
churn has submitted himself before him.
So in his heart he's like, you know
what? I've defeated him. He's been
destroyed.
Uh he's lost face. He's lost
credibility. I can let him go. I've won.
Okay? And that's what he wants to do. He
just wants to let him go. But this is
the very ending. Okay? This is the very
ending of the Iniad. And the ending is
surprising because from for many
scholars they read this they're like
this is not an ending. This is too
abrupt and they think like um Virgil was
not able to finish the INIA. But what
I'll show you is that no you're reading
the the improperly incorrectly if you do
not believe this is the full ending.
Okay. This is not the ending. Okay. Can
you read it Ivory?
>> Okay. Adidas, ferocious in armor, stood
there still shifting his gaze and held
his sword sword arm back, holding
himself back to, as Turnis' words began
to sway him more and more when all at
once he caught sight of the faithful
sword belt of Palace swept over Turnis'
shoulder gleaming with shining studs
Anas knew by heart.
>> Wait, sorry. Palace. Palace is the um
the version of Petropolis. Remember how
Petroles died and that enraged Achilles?
Well, Palace is a friend of Inas who
fell in battle to Turnis and Turnis to
celebrate his victory over Palace stole
the sword belt of Palace. Okay, so and
Inis recognizes this. Keep on going.
>> Young Palace whom Turnis had
overpowered, taken down with a wound,
and now his shoulder flaunted his
enemy's battle emblem like a trophy.
Inas soon his eyes drink in that plunder
keepsake of his savage of his own savage
grief flaring up in fury terrible in his
rage he cries decked in the spoils who
stripped someone from one I loved escape
my clutches never palace strikes this
blow palace sacrifices you now makes you
pay makes you pay the price with your
own guilty blood in the same breath
blazing with raph he plants his iron
sword held deep into his enemy's heart
turn his limb limps went limp and the
chill of death. His light breath fled
with a groan of outrage down to the
shades below.
>> And that's it. This is the ending of the
INIA. And again, scholars are confused
by this. Like how how could the um
epic end like this? It's a very long
epic, 24 books, and it ends with the
death of Turnis and nothing more.
And it's confusing because scholars and
literary critics are taught to believe
that a good book has
um an epiphany and a ctharsis. Okay,
epiphany,
karthis
and a resolution.
Basically, a character recognizes
himself and changes for the better. It's
it's almost like a death
and letting go of a pass.
And so scholars read this and like
they're completely confused. Where is
the epiphany? Where's the cartharosis?
Where's the resolution? And the answer
is because you're misreading
the INIA.
First and foremost, it is a work of
political propaganda.
So how has Inas changed as a person?
Well, the change is this. Previously,
whenever Inas has a doubt, okay?
Okay. Like for example, he is
changing his emotions.
Each time this happened previously,
the gods had to intervene, right? Do you
remember how um
Inas is back in Troy and he's witnessed
the killing of his king Pam and he's
really angry and then he sees Helen
and he wants to kill Helen because he
understand that Helen is the cause of
all the death and destruction in Troy
and he wants to like just kill her and
then what happens his mother Venus
intervenes and says no
Inas you stop. There's a mission for
you. Go complete your mission. And then
is like, "Fine, mother. I'll I I'll go
home." And then when he goes home
and he sees her um uh his son uh Ilas,
he wants to return and fight the Greeks
because he doesn't he wants to protect
his city. And then Ilas uh there's a
sign from the gods uh Ilas, his hair is
on fire. Okay, it's an image
and this tells um Inas, no, your son is
destined for great things. You must
fulfill the mission. Again, when Inas is
with Ditto, he just wants to stay stay
with Ditto and build up Carthage. And so
Jupiter has to send a messenger,
Mercury, to tell him, "No, Inas,
no, go to Italy." Okay. So each time
that Inas went off mission or he has his
own ideas, the gods have to intervene.
What makes this an epiphany a catharsis
evolution is the fact that here when
Inas wants mercy when in his heart he's
like he this is a pitiful man. It gives
me no pleasure to kill him. It gives me
no glory and honor to kill this pathetic
man. He recognizes no, I must kill him
because it is a duty. This the it is the
will of the gods.
Now he has become fully pious
and that is the
epiphany.
Okay. I must abandon all pity. I must
abandon all emotions. I must abandon my
own soul if I am to serve the gods.
He is now the perfect soldier.
And that's why
Virgil wrote the um Iniad because it is
a piece of propaganda. It's a piece of
brainwashing indoctrination where you
read it and you go on the same journey
as idiots and step by step you let go of
everything that makes you weak. Your
humanity, your willingness, your desire
to love someone, throw it out. Your
pity, your sense of decency, get rid of
it. Okay? And once you do, once you have
cleansed yourself of all human emotions,
then you can serve the gods completely.
You are now fully pious
and as such you can now complete your
mission. All right?
So that's the power of the INIA. You may
know what's happening but as you
memorize it because back then uh the way
to educate yourself was just to memorize
um memorize the poetry
you became Inius himself. Okay, you
transformed yourself from someone who
was a human to someone who is now
basically a robot. Okay, does that make
sense? Okay, any questions?
>> Yeah. Can can you Yeah.
Um yeah, I think it's true that like
Anias, he didn't felt empathy towards um
Turnis because he killed him later, but
I I I mean I think that is still because
like he love Palace, his friend whom was
killed by Turnis. So that's also kind of
filling, right? That's an emotion that
and that's contributes to Turner's
death. So, isn't that different from
what you said about maybe Anias being a
robot and fulfilling his fate?
>> Okay. Yeah. All right. That's that's a
good point. Okay. So, um your point is
well, Inas loves his friend Palace
and as a result, it's his love for
Palace that drives Inas to kill
Charas. Right, that's fine. That makes
sense. But go back to the Iliad, right?
Where Achilles is saddened and anger by
the death of Petropolis
and he kills Hector, right?
But then what happens? He falls into a
deep depression because in his heart he
recognizes that you don't avenge
someone you love by killing someone.
That's not how the universe works. You
if you truly love someone, you do not
turn the memory of that person into
hatred and violence.
You celebrate the person's life by being
open and generous with others. Okay? And
this is something that Dante will will
explain. This is a very hard idea to
understand. Okay? But if you truly love
someone, love means that you cannot do
something evil. Love is pure good. If
you do something evil, it means you
actually don't love that person. Okay?
Does that make sense to you? If you
truly love Palace as a person, you would
not use him as an excuse to kill
someone.
All right?
So maybe with with with the Iliad where
Achilles thought he loved Petropolis but
he was actually using Petropolis as an
excuse to kill F4 and in his heart he
knows that
right this is really confusing to
understand but when when we divine
comedy it will make sense to you right
okay all right any more questions guys
okay yeah so that's a great question and
it shows teach you how
um basically in this world this is a
world of anti- love
because
you've been you received an education in
utility right obedience compliance
but what you have not received is an
education in love what is love
how do we know we're in love, what draws
us to love. Okay? And that's what the
great books are about. The great books
even Homer and Dante, they really think
deeply about what love is because in
love is where God is.
All right. Okay. So, so again by by
asking this question, what what what
you're really doing is revealing the
sort of education you you've received
when your mind you think that what is
right is one of utility. And we're when
when one of compliance if Palace my best
friend died then I need to seek
vengeance against the person who killed
him. Okay.
But I know it's hard to understand but
that is but you've been brainwashed to
think that. That's not actually true.
If your best friend were to be killed
someone else
to demonstrate love to your best friend,
you would actually forgive that person.
Okay. And I I I know this is a hard idea
to understand, but when we read Divine
Comedy, it'll become more obvious. Okay.
Okay. Any any more questions, guys?
All right. So, let me explain the plan
for Divine Comedy, which we will end the
semester with. Okay. So, there'll be
four lectures on Divine Comedy. So, I'll
I'll be doing a lecture every two weeks.
All right. And then for the other
classes, we'll just be reading divine
harmony line by line by line. All right.
Okay. All right. So, uh we we start the
divine harmony on Friday. All right.
Very good.
Do you do you understand? Okay. It's
very hard idea to understand. Okay. But
it's hard. It's hard idea to understand
just because I hate to say this, but but
but you've been brainwashed.